I want to show a picture of you from
True Blood and there you are in
character and I'm noticing next to me
you guys are like the palest people on
television and I'm curious you can't
because of the role that you play you
really have to be careful about getting
any color at all don't you yeah we have
a fantastic makeup artist though so
she'll just dip us in white when we show
up right this is me when they try to
make me look like I have human skin tone
seriously this is like flowers a bit of
blush it's that's all painted on yeah
yeah but it would look like the kid from
chalk if I'm when I walk around in life
yeah but but also it's in your it's in
your nature you were born in Sweden is
that right yeah and and I'm just tell me
about that culture that culture has
always fascinated me first what's in my
nature well I've noticed that looking
that you pay oh you're blonde you're
paying out your nature your physical
makeup but but also I've noticed that
you have and I've looked at the films
that you're in right now and Trueblood
you're very proud of your body is that
is that a Swedish would you say no I
mean there's no body shame I guess
that's no but there's a difference I
don't think it's about being proud of
your body or not it's kind of being
comfortable and and you know it's it's I
think it's less stigmatized nudity in
Sweden than it is here people are
comfortable being nude
what now people who if you haven't been
to Sweden you imagine like people
walking down the streets of likes
there's polar bears and nude people
everywhere it's that point like that I'm
seeing nude people riding polar bears
[Applause]
the same thought in my head pretty much
that's what people are thinking right
now I think in general people are
slightly more comfortable with new to
the nudity and Sweden and and I also
come from a family my dad and especially
his side of the family are old hippies
and Bohemians and I think it was 14 the
first time I saw my dad wearing pants oh
[Laughter]
he was always naked always naked
well he's like at the ATM getting
Kitty's ring name I mean around the
house obviously butt-naked really naked
but what naked everything I mean yes he
cooked I mean he was always like if he
was in at he was a stage actor my father
is also an actor and mostly in films now
but now I was the kid he was the stage
actors talking so when he was when he
wasn't at the theater he'd be at home
cooking or just chilling with no clothes
on I think cooking with no clothes would
be hazardous you know it's not that big
so it's fine
[Applause]
you mean the building the stove right
this stove I'm saying the stove is
really low problem dad's gonna love this
little chick
it's average plus no but the thing is so
for me was just very I didn't think this
is going really well yeah it is going
really well
but I didn't really care about it really
I mean that's the way I was raised and
it was until we started me and my
brother started bringing girls over that
then we felt a little uncomfortable
about it didn't walk into me like hello
ladies who's your friend that my brother
got remember my my brother
I just I don't know it well yeah I'm it
fascinates me because I come from an
extremely uptight Irish culture where
I'm wearing this in the bathtub
you know this is I I'm never naked I've
never been seen nude there's no there's
no moment in my life when I'm naked so I
am I'm jealous of that sort of sense of
freedom no yeah I think it's it's
wonderful but that was a that point I
think we felt because at my all my
buddies were always at my place and my
brothers as well their kid buddies were
always hanging out at our place but and
people were so we used to it they didn't
really care you know that was always
like walking around cooking with a glass
of wine not you know naked on but yes we
had a head way out of talk with that
when when went out we were teens were
like that like when we bring girls over
could you just please put on a robe or
something like you're scaring them